avoir des enfants
notre ami nounours est allé à la pêche
aujourd'hui trop il ne faut pas le dire
je n'ai pas mon permis non mais tu n'es
pas pêcheur bien dangereux et qu'as tu
attrapes et sera c'est une surprise pour
mes amis qui m'attendent pour les sols
vas-y doucement nounours t'as surprise
et peut être fragile sevrin hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop
des charges ne bousculez pas alors tous
bons c'est une surprise l'udc était
gentil alors on ferme les yeux c'est
l'anti des
[Musique]
droits ça y est ça les
dépasse en couilles je les ai pêché pour
vous merci mon nounou merci non c'était
vraiment chic ce qu'ils sont mignons
c'est plus du point tu crois qu'ils
veulent devenir grand oui si vous les
choyer bien mais les poissons rouges ne
devienne jamais très très gros est
simple et joli dis moi je vais bien me
soigner ses petits mais où vas tu nies
color
voilà je vais leur faire des tartines de
camembert diaquem
oui ils vont grandir et bien se porter
mais nicolas les poissons rouges ne
mange pas de cabre bain
à temps j'aime l'idée petits poissons je
vous trouve bien fillon cette fois ça va
leur plaire et st600 clos nicolas pas de
106 on attend j'ai apporté
or j'avais une boîte à ça ou donc et
elle vous êtes mal à tous les gays
voilà donner des miettes de pain il
serait gay bravo pas preneur demain
j'apporterai ma boîte de friandises pour
poissons apporte aussi un peu de sable
fin et quelques cailloux n'oublie pas
non je n'oublierai pas allons ce l'heure
de laisser dormir ces jeunes poissons
[Musique]
nuit petit prince ou
nicolas premiers mois de ne pas leur
donner à manger du saucisson et du cab
robert
pas les laisser avoir faim au je vais
être obligé de remporter ces poisons en
état
ou laden seulement des miettes de bons
mais demain je viendrai très vite voir
si c'est vrai
[Musique]
à demain petit diable de nicolas beau ne
nuit pas preneur
honneur
[Musique]
ou
qui at-il nounours j'ai quelques soucis
pas trop ce petit nico l'or a encore
voulu te faire marcher mais c'était pour
rire pourvu qu'ils leur donnent pas du
camembert allant un route banni les
enfants fait de pur
[Musique]
et